I don't think there is a contradiction
between a simple life and a spicy food
perhaps someone who's living a simple
life needs to have something to spice it
up maybe that works
my name is father Richard walls and I am
a monk of Subiaco abbey which is a
monastery and Subiaco Arkansas after I
graduated from high school I entered the
monastery so I've been 55 years a monk
monk sauce which we produce here at
Subiaco Abbey is an Abba narrow pepper
sauce we call that monk sauce because
it's monk made anybody who has handled
oven or peppers knows that you should
not be doing this without a glove on a
good month is a good balance between
prayer and work
it ought to be done find out if it's any
good where's the water
I suspect a lot of people have kind of
fanciful ideas about monks and what they
do and they get into the monastery and
they find out that monks are very much
like everybody else I feel very close
connection to the land in this area the
longer that I was here the more I
realized that God got me here because he
knew how to be in a community the
community is a very important thing to
me
you